[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 17 mai voici les
titres c'est la journée mondiale de
lutte contre l'homophobie dans les
yvelines une pièce de théâtre et si on
se disait tous aborde la thématique avec
humour pour promouvoir l'acceptation de
la différence une comédie d'éric marty
auteur comédien et metteur en scène qui
est notre invité l'union de la gauche se
lance dans la campagne des élections
législatives les 12 candidats yvelinois
de nu ps ont été présentés en fin de
semaine dernière à guyancourt s'il
s'agit surtout de profil de la france
insoumis certaines circonscriptions
étaient réservés à d'autres formations
le point à suivre et puis c'est une
première dans les yvelines ben va
disposer d'un éco garde communale un
partenariat a été signé en ce sens et le
recrutement est lancé quelles sont les
missions d'un écogarde reportage à la
fin de cette édition
mais avant de développer ses titres
c'est la grande fête du cinéma le 75e
festival de cannes débute ce soir avec
la cérémonie d'ouverture à 19 heures
pendant la quinzaine radio sensations en
partenariat avec tv 78 citizen kane tv
est sur place on retrouve d'ailleurs
depuis la croisette corentin alonso la
75e édition du festival de cannes
démarre aujourd'hui pendant deux
semaines radio sensations vous proposera
de rencontrer les franciliens qui font
vivre le cinéma qu'ils soient
exploitants acteurs réalisateurs ou
producteurs la région ile de france
justement poursuit son soutien à
l'industrie du cinéma avec un budget
annuel de près de 25 millions d'euros
elle accompagne chaque année environ 150
films 21 d'entre eux seront mises à
l'honneur cette année au festival de
cannes parmi eux le film coupé de michel
hazanavicius la région ile de france l'a
soutenu à hauteur de 360 2000 euros au
titre du fonds de soutien il sera
projeté ce soir dès la cérémonie
d'ouverture
laurent il vieira tir à muriel bien
natsumi et anaïs elle devient chine à
sous et moi je suis tiennent par contre
rigole pas non non et j'te jure teuma
pas c'est moi qui suis allé grand max
tu m'étonnes que je fixe et
mobile tu viens ta gueule tu me fais
chier de bénéteau début des répétitions
saloperie dont on vit
[Musique]
je vous en parlais dans les titres ce
mardi 17 mai c'est la journée mondiale
de lutte contre l'homophobie et la
transphobie le but c'est de sensibiliser
et prévenir lors de cette date qui est
symbolique le 17 mai 1990
l'homosexualité est retiré de la liste
des maladies mentales de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé dans les yvelines
pour parler de ce sujet on a choisi le
théâtre et on en parle justement avec
mon invité eric marty bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes auteur comédien metteur en
scène d' aventure artistique production
qui est basée à verneuil sur seine et
vous signez et si on se disait tous est
une comédie qui parle de l'homophobie et
qui est en tournée en ce moment on
regarde tout de suite un extrait de la
bande annonce
elle est
une femme
on parle donc d'homophobie avec le
prisme de l'humour on va on va en parler
dans un instant déjà un pitch sûr sur
cette pièce il ya deux personnages on va
suivre les aventures de carole et
patrick c'est un couple ordinaire et qui
n'est pas encore mariée c'est ça c'est
ça c'est un couple totalement ordinaire
ça fait cinq ans qu'ils sont ensemble
tout va bien sauf que mais il ya des
mensonges et au sein du de ce futur
couple puisque
carole n'a pas dit à patrick qu'elle
travaillait pour le refuge qui héberge
les jeunes homosexuels et pour patrick
qui pensent que c'est un refuge pour
animaux donc déjà ça ça pose problème et
en plus le frère de patrick est lui même
homosexuel mais ça ne le sait pas parce
que ce jeune frère gilles a été mis à la
porte de chez eux de chercher de leurs
parents et à 5 ans et quand ils se sont
retrouvés il n'a pas voulu noircir le
tableau comédie et donc il a menti il a
rien dit il ya toute une histoire les
parlements ti évidemment donc
patrick ne sait pas que son frère son
jeune frère est homo et ne sait pas que
tant que sa compagne travaille pour leur
fusion forcément quiproquos et on
découvre très vite que patrick est un
peu homophobe des comédies il a des
problèmes avec les gais et donc deux
personnages pour entrer dans cette
histoire c'est carole et patrick est
aussi le personnage de gil trois
personnages dans cette pièce en août
trois personnages ou là une comédie plus
réduite en un personnage
tout tourne autour de ces trois
personnages qui se montrent finalement
est alors y en a deux autres un qui
n'apparaissent pas en scène c'est la
future belle mère jeanine qui est très
présente ce qu'elle appelle trois fois
par jour vient de quatre fois par
semaine est embêté grand dam de patrick
et puis il ya l'ancien petit ami de
gilles qui veut absolument lui parler
tout au long de la pièce pour lui dire
quelque chose d'important on découvre à
la fin tout à la fin pourquoi il
voudrait vrai il veut vraiment lui
parler personnellement ailleurs à tous
tout le monde essaye de lui parler
directement de savoir ce qu'il veut et
finalement on découvre à la fin le
pot-aux-roses voilà elle aborde donc la
thématique de l'homophobie avec humour
on met la partie humour deux côtés mais
déjà pourquoi choisir de parler de
l'homophobie avant d'en parler avec
humour justement alors toutes mes pièces
c'est la quatrième que j'écris toutes
mes pièces ont un fond social je voulais
voilà donc la dea l'avant dernière étape
mais on en fait quoi qui est
actuellement de 6 en tournée c'était sur
la dépendance les ai pas de scandale etc
on est encore des jeunes en plein dans
l'actualité et la celle ci je voulais un
thème qu'ils soient un peu plus fort
parce que je voulais surtout un peu plus
d'émotion donc a déjà l'écriture je
voulais un peu plus d'émotion parce
qu'en tant que comédien j'avais déjà
ressenti dans ma toute première pièce
que passer du rire aux larmes de prendre
les spectateurs comme ça
d'une réplique à une autre entre la
comédie et tout d'un coup le drame parce
que l'histoire de j lui parce qu'il a
été mis à la porte de chez lui de chez
eux et du jeu fait même pas du jour au
lendemain c'est du sûr le soir même le
père a lancé toutes ses valises à la
porte et voilà donc je voulais quelque
chose de plus qu'il ya un mélange
d'émotions de rires mais c'est avant
tout une comédie on rit voilà justement
comment on en parle avec humour de ce
sujet c c java dire c'est très simple
belle dans l'extrait convient de voir
voilà on découvre que patrick et
homophobes et donc ça pourrait se pose
évidemment problème et en même temps
on va creuser voilà donc à travers le
rire parce que le couple se déchire
c'est comme tous les couples donc là la
femme la carole va essayer de le elle
fait beaucoup de gars fin surtout donc
elle a tendance à allanche est un peu le
morceau assez facilement donc forcément
il ya du rire parce que le public est
complice le public s'est très vite que
gilles petit frère est hypocondriaque et
homosexuels
évidemment mais il sait très bien aussi
que patrick ne le sait pas ne sait rien
du tout quand on parle de refuge
forcément c'est les rires voilà donc à
travers le rire ont passé mais il
m'arrive plus facilement à faire passer
des messages c'est l'acceptation des
autres des différences c'est à dire que
le public est scotché quoi on rit
vraiment et puis tout d'un coup on
raconte à travers les deux frères qui a
moment s'explique parce que c'est la
belle mère qui va faire la gueule
on raconte la vraie histoire ce qui
s'est vraiment passé ce soir là et là
tout d'un coup paf on passe
on passe pas dans le drame et dans
l'émotion on a eu des retours de
spectateurs qui avaient la larme à
l'oeil quand on a un voilà donc c'est
c'est ça c'est la surprise c'est le du
rire à l'émotion en une réplique une et
comment vous est venue l'idée les
origines du projet ça remonte à quand
comment ça s'est concrétisé ça remonte
un dernier confinement
inspirant pour certains auteurs - cours
d'autres pour vous à la fin de chaque
représentation ma précédente pièce est à
mais on en fait quoi tous les
organisateurs venaient me voir en disant
alors la prochaine la prochaine et puis
je leur disais vous savez entre de
confinement les couvre feux et cetera
gpat convient d'écrire des comédies
notamment parce que moi j'ai écrit que
des comédies mans même si un fonds
social et puis finalement modérée
complètement décembre 2020 j'avais du
temps le sujet c'était un sujet porteur
pour le coup bon même si les choses ont
évolué il ya quand même
encore beaucoup de travail
voilà je me suis mis à l'écriture ça a
été assez rapide il a fallu trouver une
distribution on est en résidence savez
on a la chance d'être à devenir mature
c'est loin du strass maurice béjart bon
voilà tout ça s'est un peu concrétisée
assez rapidement mais finalement le
thème était quand même très très porteur
puis j'ai eu des retours de deux ans je
travaille dans une vie artistique en
plus elle était jouée pour la première
fois le 27 mars dernier quels sont les
retours ils ont été plutôt bons et
excellents on avait fait une petite
avant première
au mois de février première test
avant-première tests et déjà le public
crier bravo à la fin ne nous était
jamais arrivé dans toutes les tournées
que j'ai fait et le 27 mars pareil à
verneuil sur seine
pareil mais bravo à la fin des gens dans
le hall notamment à monsieur ça m'a
marqué qu il me dit très sérieusement le
message est bien passé qu'il me fait je
ne sais pas s'il avait des choses très
personnelles derrière ça et puis on
avait aussi des retours de gens qui ont
qui nous ont dit des émules à là on
était pas loin et c'est à la salle
pousser à la réflexion c'était aussi le
but de cette pièce est ce qu'elle va
être jouée dans d'autres villes des
yvelines peut-être d'autres villes de
france alors j'aimerais bien je vous
mentirais en disant que j'ai plein de
dates j'ai plein de pistes pour
l'instant rien de signé donc si vos
téléspectateurs ont des propositions qui
n'hésite pas parce que c'est très dur la
culture en ce moment voilà depuis
janvier on s'aperçoit que c'est vraiment
très très difficile donc j'ai beaucoup
de pistes rien de signé j'espère que le
sujet n'est pas rébarbatif je sais
j'espère pas en tout cas ça reste une
comédie nourrit évidemment beaucoup le
public il prend ce qu'il veut si le
message passe très bien s'il ya une
seule personne des parents qu'ils
s'aperçoivent que leur enfant était un
peu différent ils se poseront peut-être
des questions parce que l'histoire de
gilles qu'on met à la porte c'est quand
même très dur
heureusement qu'il ya justement
l'association le refuge voilà donc la
promo là on part sur avignon enfin pas
nous mais le festival va se faire donc
on relance toute la communication en
septembre et le message est passé on
retrouve peut-être toutes les
informations sur le site d' aventure
artistique production il s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci eric marty d'être
venu parler de cette pièce en plateau
merci à vous je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur le comédien est aussi le
metteur en scène de cette pièce et si on
se disait tous
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité ce chiffre
6872 le nombre de chefs d'entreprise qui
ont perdu leur activité professionnelle
en 2021 en ile-de-france et
l'observatoire de l'emploi des
entrepreneurs qui le révèle dans le
détail cela concerne dans les yvelines
412 entrepreneurs même si ce chiffre
apparaît élevé il est en baisse par
rapport à 2020 - 10,9 pour cent les
chefs d'entreprise seniors ou ceux
exerçant dans les secteurs de la
construction et du commerce sont les
plus impactées
politique à présent les élections
législatives sont au programme les 12 et
19 juin prochains à gauche les candidats
yvelinois de nubes ou nuque est la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale ont été présentés il y avait
quelques jours à guyancourt l'occasion
de faire le point sur le découpage des
circonscriptions yvelinoise pour
l'alliance avec bixente mayence insisté
ban
lann ubs nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale est en campagne
dans les yvelines les deux candidats
sont aujourd'hui connus grâce à un
travail débuté avant l'officialisation
de l' des coupes nationales on a eu ce
réflexe d'aller bosser ensemble de
réfléchir déjà à la question des
suppléants comment on pouvait renforcer
nos campagnes les uns les autres et ce
soir je me réjouis que presque toutes
les sensibilités des yvelines était
présente douze circonscriptions pour
cinq formations politiques différentes
les trois quarts issus de la france
insoumise but nous gâchent pour certains
candidats de découvrir ou redécouvrir le
territoire yvelinois j'étais étudiant à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines je suis très content plus de
dix ans après de revenir cette fois un
candidat à une élection et en disant si
vous m'élisez si vous choisissez une
majorité de la nouvelle union populaire
à l'assemblée nationale qui mélenchon
est premier ministre et ben on va donner
les moyens aux jeunes de pouvoir faire
des études vous savez quand on est
militant politique on est partout chez
soi pour mener les combats parce qu'en
réalité aujourd'hui sur la 8e
circonscription des yvelines je suis le
seul candidat qui propose de défendre la
retraite à 60 ans l'assemblée nationale
et qui sera présent pour mener toutes
ces batailles pour la justice pour le
climat pour la démocratie
true trop longtemps entendu les gens se
plaindre de la désunion et puis s'était
répété on prouve le contraire tant mieux
horizons différents et profil différent
de la parité déjà avec six femmes et six
hommes mais aussi la jeunesse en
témoigne victor palak 20 ans c'est la
diversité et c'est l'espoir en fait
c'est la diversité de tous les profils
de cette union des partis de gauche
écologistes et c'est l'espoir l'espoir
de ce troisième tour et de dire ça y est
on peut peut-être vraiment changer les
choses un autre monde est encore
possible la force et le programme
l'union elle s'est faite autour d'un
programme et on donne ou aux électeurs
électrices une perspective de victoire
qui est crédit mais qui est sérieuse
la nuit pèse c'est un programme mise en
commun mais aussi un combat contre la
majorité présidentielle
je suis candidate pour prendre la place
de béatrice piron elle a voté tout ce
que lui a demandé de voter macron et
c'est tout c'est en fait la députée mme
acronis de base donc moi mon objectif
c'est d'être de prendre sa place pour
porter la voix de tous ceux qui ne sont
pas représentés à l'assemblée nationale
il nous faut comme à grignon dire stop
un autre monde est possible quelque
chose d'autre est possible où nous
pouvons tous ensemble vivre au mieux les
français doivent ôter s'exprimer s'ils
veulent un changement de politique dans
ce pays il faut qu'ils viennent voter
cette volonté de cohabitation entre
assemblée nationale et gouvernement
portées par les candidats du ps aura la
réponse du peuple dans moins d'un mois
verdict les 12 et 19 juin prochains
c'est nouveau dans le département la
commune de ben a signé un dispositif une
convention plus exactement avec
écogardes ce partenariat va permettre de
créer de recruter le premier éco garde
communale dans les yvelines quelles sont
ses missions sensibilisation ou
répression les précisions de mathilde
franco
le recrutement est en cours depuis
plusieurs jours après avoir signé une
convention avec le dispositif écogardes
la commune de ben souhaitent s'investir
davantage dans la préservation de
l'environnement et recherche son futur
éco garde communale c'est la première
ville des yvelines à franchir le cap ça
fait plus d'un an que je travaille sur
le sujet et
j'avais quand même de bonne espérance
mais aussi vite je pensais pas et là je
suis très très fier du chemin tout seul
est très fier de mon équipe aussi que
derrière qui est très fier ça va aller
dans la continuité ça va pérenniser le
le poste l'idée et puis ça empêchera pas
qu'ils aient toujours ce système
bénévoles loin de là on sera toujours là
mais du coup ça va appuyer comme le
disait
mary bale fait tout à l'heure voilà
c'est ça fait aussi des contacts aussi
plus fixe pour un ensemble de choses et
d'action en complément de la police
municipale l'écogarde agira surtout sur
tout ce qui touche à la protection de la
nature si son rôle est avant tout de
sensibiliser et de valoriser les espaces
naturels de la commune et leur a aussi
la possibilité de verbaliser les
incivilités les coquins dans le
dispositif il a une de ses missions
c'est surtout aller au contact des gens
et c'est vraiment un ensemble entre la
on a la surveillance on sensibilise les
gens ont fait beaucoup de pédagogie m6
va lancer beaucoup d'appels publics et
puis à dire aux gens ce qu'ils ont à
faire ce qu'on ne peut pas faire s'ils
pouvaient déclencheur au niveau du
département alors là bravo il ya
d'autres communes ont des conventions
mais n'ont pas forcément un lien
personnel qui sera embauchée
spécialement pour ça vous formez bouffon
nous on à la police municipale on a un
des postes qui a été réservé pour ça sur
quatre en fait on montre la volonté
selon le nouvel éco garde aura aussi
pour mission d'être le référent en lien
avec les brigades de gendarmerie dans le
cadre du protocole jantes vers cet outil
de discussion en ligne permet notamment
aux élus de la commune de signaler des
dépôts sauvages
trappeur ans thomas ja samuel pâtit
samedi dernier la ville a inauguré un
jardin portant le nom du professeur
d'histoire-géographie tués le 16 octobre
2020 par un terroriste à conflans sainte
honorine il est situé au coeur du
quartier des merisiers rue gérard
philipe la volonté d'en faire un îlot de
fraîcheur avec la plantation de 28
nouveaux arbres et des espaces de jeux y
sont également installés pour les
enfants en table pour jouer aux dames
pergola avec brumisateur ou encore agrès
de fitness
attrape toujours une nouvelle
association vient de s'implanter fête le
mur créée en 1996 par yannick noah elle
vise à développer l'insertion et
l'éducation par la pratique du tennis
chez les jeunes des quartiers
prioritaires la journée de lancement
s'est déroulé samedi dernier au complexe
youri gagarine au programme stands
d'insertion professionnelle ce temps
d'éducation alimentaire une découverte
du tennis fauteuil et de l'urban tennis
au programme et au total une centaine de
jeunes étaient présents sur la journée
un projet en partenariat avec la
municipalité de trappes qui vise à
rendre le sport accessible à tous on
écoute les propos recueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude sur l'initiation au
tennis on a déjà une vingtaine de jeunes
qui reviennent chaque semaine parce
qu'on a déjà commencé des séances
hebdomadaires en amont de ce lancement
officiel et on a des jeunes qui sont
déjà intéressés par l'arbitrage qui sont
déjà intéressés par le ramassage de
balle donc peut-être des jeunes qui
seront à roland garros dans quelques
années montera en puissance à la rentrée
de septembre on ira visait les 16 25 ans
avec une dimension qui me tient à coeur
également c'est la dimension liées à
l'insertion professionnelle
comment est-ce qu'on utilise le sport le
tennis en particulier pour remobiliser
des jeunes qui sont décrocheurs qui ont
des difficultés d'insertion que pas
forcément diplôme pas forcément un
travail qui se cherche dans la vie et
qui pourront avec un coaching un
accompagnement spécialisé un
accompagnement social aussi avec
l'association de prévention spécialisée
pouvoir reprendre confiance en eux
pratiquer cette activité sportive mais
de moi j'espère trouver un job et avant
de vous laisser c'est un rendez vous
traditionnel tous les ans la nuit des
musées a pris place dans divers lieux
culturels de france pour cette occasion
le musée d'archéologie nationale de
saint germain en laye ouvert ses portes
gratuitement le 14 mai retour avec
céline charles et patrick jacques de
dixmude
entrer dans la cour du château de
saint-germain-en-laye avec le rythme de
la batucada brésilienne et se laisser
guider par les ombres et lumières
c'était la proposition réussite du musée
d'archéologie nationale de la ville pour
la nuit des musées 2022 plusieurs
animations étaient au programme avec un
accent cette année sur le célèbre
dramaturge molière le château abrite
comme ce que vous pouvez entendre
derrière moi la magnifique scène est un
cri ont été réinterprétés
à part une troupe de comédiens grâce au
théâtre alexandre dumas c'est un
partenariat qui nous permet de faire
revivre quelque part c'est comédie créée
directement au château de saint germain
va présenter monsieur de pourceaugnac
qui est une comédie ballet après on a
présenté les fourberies de scapin
ensuite la jalousie du barbouillé une
petite farce en un acte et on a fini
avec
le malade imaginaire de ces soirées
comme ça un petit peu de la magie dans
l'air et puis de l'énergie qui nous est
donné par ses acteurs ses fantastiques
et molière quelle modernité ça redonne
envie de dos de redécouvrir molière
incroyable un extérieur festif qui mène
à la visite du musée d'archéologie
nationale depuis plusieurs éditions des
médiateurs étudiants en partenariat avec
l'université paris dauphine et l'école
du louvre sont présents dans chaque
salle pour guider le public l'occasion
pour les petits comme pour les plus
grands de découvrir autrement les lieux
c'est aussi une expérience pour nous
d'apprendre à présenter en fait des
vestiges archéologiques que même nous
forcément n'est pas spécialiste en la
matière c'est pas vraiment notre
domaines d'action prioritaires du pont
on apprend en fait ce soir on n'a pas
affaire à des spécialistes de
l'archéologie mais vraiment à des
étudiants qui a envie de partager un
moment avec les gens qui déambulent dans
les espaces est donc partagée aussi
leurs coups de coeur dans ses différents
espaces très intéressante et
enrichissante 6 à des guides dans tous
les
dans toutes les salles du
c'est encore plus prenant et
compréhensible pour nous le château a
été battue ont fait a été construit par
rapport à la chapelle qui était déjà
existante depuis des siècles et des
siècles mais ça ça nous fait découvrir
vraiment l'histoire
de la france dans un cadre idyllique et
avec la magie de la tombée de la nuit la
nuit des musées au musée d'archéologie
nationale est un événement qui attire
chaque année son public près de 2500
personnes ont répondu présent ce soir là
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant le 7-8
culture présentée par célia tsongo belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]